Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Sind wir ganz entspannt. Wir haben eine Woche Pause gehabt.
Ja, die hatten wir ja nicht, weil wir entspannt waren. Insofern ähm ich weiß nicht, was warst du entspannt?
Ich bin immer entspannt.
Nicht wahr? Also war auch entspannt, ja, aber jetzt nicht. Na, jetzt ist gerade auch entspannt, ja.
Warte, sehr gut. Aber trotzdem Podcast mache.
Ach nee, komm, lass mal heute mal aus.
Na ja, äh entscheidend ist die äh äh Themenlage im Netz politischen, letzpolitischen Wäldchen,
Ähm jetzt haben wir die Frage, welche äh äh Trolle und Zwerge da gerade äh herumhüpfen und äh ums Lagerfeuer hüpfen.
Ja
Sind so ein bisschen wieder die alten Waldgeister, ne.
Die alten Waldgäste, aber bevor wir zu denen kommen, muss ich noch etwas äh richtig stellen. Aus der letzten Sendung, wo es um die GEMA ging. Da habe ich so leichtfertig
ähm Doktor Mottes Aussage übernommen, dass äh die GEMA gerne zehn Prozent von den Clubs haben möchte.
Das ist vom Eintritt.
Vom Eintritt, genau, das ist rein rechnerisch kommt das hin,
Das ist ungefähr zehn Prozent sind. Es ist aber eine gestaffelte Tabelle, die sich dahinter verbirgt, die nach eintritts äh Preis und Fläche des Clubs,
Ähm und wenn man dann da hochrechnet, ungefähr bei zehn Prozent liegt. Ja, also das heißt der der Schlüssel, den sie im Schnitt ungefähr bei zehn Prozent liegt. Aber der dahinter verbirgt sich so eine Tabelle, weiß ich nicht, bis so und so viel,
Quadratmeter, bis der und der Dauer bis Quadratmeter bis der Dauer und so weiter,
und da verbirgt sich dann äh eine eine Preisstaffelung hinter. Das heißt also, es ist an die äh es ist an den
eintritt und an äh und beziehungsweise und an die Fläche gebunden. Daraus ergibt sich dieser Verteilungsschlüssel. Bei der Fläche gab's dann noch das Problem, dass sie auch die Fläche jetzt neu berechnen und auch ähm,
Also wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, quasi die gesamte Grundfläche nehmen, inklusive irgendwie dem Barbereich und so, während man vorher in solchen Fragen
nach,
nach der Tanzfläche oder so gegangen ist. Ja, das heißt, da da ist dann die Fläche, die die Fläche wird also größer und dann gibt's also einen Schlüssel, mit wie hoch ist der Eintritt, äh wie viel Fläche hat der Laden? Und ähm,
Wie viel Geld möchte die GEMA dann haben? Und entsprechend würde das dann so auf ähm ist das immer so, dass man so ungefähr bei zehn Prozent landet.
Das noch als äh weitere Erläuterung zu dem Thema.
Gut, dann schreiten wir zu den anderen Aufregern.
Ja äh wir haben ja, weil wir letzte Woche kein kein Podcast gemacht haben, haben wir, wären wir jetzt so, glaube ich, so das letzte äh deutsche Qualitätsmedium sein, was verkündet, dass äh Acta abgelehnt wurde.
Finalemente im Europaparlament.
Ja, neununddreißig Abgeordnete sprachen sich dafür aus. Neununddreißig, immerhin, ja. Äh hundertfünfundsechzig Enthaltung, vierhundertachtundsiebzig Gegenstimmen.
Ja, also die neununddreißig, das ist quasi so die Sperrspitze der digitalen.
Muss, ja? Mhm. Ja.
Revolution oder was auch immer. Und ähm,
Dann gab's natürlich jetzt tausende von Stimmen und und jeder Verband hat irgendwas dazu gesagt und weil einige waren froh, einige waren nicht froh und ähm ich will das jetzt gar nicht mehr so ähm.
So detailliert jetzt ausbreiten wollen in der Futz hatte, da gab's dann irgendeinen Artikel, wo dann gesagt wurde, jetzt jetzt regiert hier auf einmal der Mob und macht die macht die äh schönen Ideen kaputt,
hat offensichtlich irgendwie verpasst äh mitzubekommen, dass da ein Parlament abgestimmt hat oder so. Also war auf jeden Fall großes großes Bohei, um,
um diese Ablehnung. Brauchen wir aber glaube ich jetzt gar nicht mehr so zu rekapitulieren, denn was viele interessanter ist, ähm ist, wie geht's denn jetzt nach Akta weiter?
Und da wurden jetzt sehr schön zusammengefasst, was wie so Aktas Nachfolger heißen, weil ich ja schon so gesagt hatte, solche Kämpfe werden ja eigentlich immer nur Etappenmäßig geworden, bis dann der nächste ähm,
Vorschlag kommt und in diesem Falle äh sind das jetzt erstmal in konkreter Nähe äh ähm fünf Stück.
Ja ähm eine zwischen EU und Kanada,
dann die also auch wieder in der EU da diskutiert werden soll. Dann,
Das äh Partnership der USA mit äh Australien Bruno, Malaysia, Neuseeland und so weiter. Ähm,
Dann G acht Pläne, die auch irgendwie sowas wie freiwillige Aktionen des Privatsektors äh beinhalten,
Äh allerdings ISP ist nicht direkt erwähnen. Es könnte also sein, dass die so aus aus Acta gelernt haben und dann den,
das Fortschreiten der ITU. Das war jetzt 'ne lange Liste.
Das Fortschreiten der ITU?
Ja, also die ITU, das wäre ist auch, glaube ich, das Thema, was man von denen jetzt ein bisschen ausführlicher behandeln sollte. Die ITU ist ja die International Telekommunikation, denke ich mal, also internationale Fernmeldeunion. Und ähm,
da die haben also ist eine Sonderorganisation der Vereinigten Nationen,
Sind insgesamt hundertdreiundneunzig Mitgliedsländer drin vertreten und die machen die,
Die gibt's irgendwie seit neunzehnhundertachtundachtzig und das ist sein weltweit geltender Vertrag für den Betrieb und die Abrechnung von äh Telekommunikationsdiensten.
Und jetzt geht die ITU hin und sagt, ja
oder beziehungsweise die Mitgliedsländer Russland, China vor allem und sagen, ja wir wollen aber jetzt mal irgendwie diese ITR ähm reformieren
muss irgendwie jetzt auch mal Internet mit äh kontrolliert werden.
Internet, kontrolliert von der ITU.
Ja, wollen so ein bisschen also eine Art.
Geile Idee.
Aufsichtsgremium quasi. Da.
Ja. Geile Idee. Dass das aus China und Russland kommt, das äh wundert mich ja auch nicht, auch nur eine Sekunde.
Also ich meine ITU, da muss man echt noch mal ein bisschen ausholen, ne.
Genau, das würde mich freuen, wenn du das.
Also äh.
Die ETU gibt's halt schon seit Ewigkeiten, dann sagen wir, hat auch ihre wichtige Rolle gespielt, aber was man sich klar machen muss, die ITU, das ist so quasi die die das Welttreffen,
a la Telekom Bösewichte überhaupt, ja, vielleicht ist das Wort jetzt schon ein bisschen überzogen, aber machen wir uns klar, wer da sozusagen wirkt, dass es so quasi geboren auf so Unternehmen wie deutsche Bundespost und
und AT und T, also alle großen nationalen Telekommunikations ähm,
Organisationen, ne, also damals als Telekommunikation im Wesentlichen noch aus Telefon äh bestand und äh und sowas und
vor allem eben auch eine nationale Aufgabe war, bevor es dann eben äh schrittweise in den letzten,
zwanzig Jahren weltweit eigentlich fast überall mit wenigen Ausnahmen ähm privatisiert worden ist.
Das ist das, was die ITU ist. Und das hat irgendwie seine Vorteile, was sagen wir mal so standardisierung betrifft, ja, das ist ja so, also wenn mal da sich auf was geeinigt wird, dann,
dann funktioniert das auch. Sowas wie internationaler Telefonverkehr und so. Das ist ja alles sagen wir mal wirklich nachhaltige äh,
nachhaltiger Technologieverbund. Da ist es eben gelungen über einen längeren Zeitraum wirklich sinnvolle Telekommunikationsstrukturen im Telefoniebereich zumindest zu schaffen.
Also du meinst Telefoniebereich, meinst du zum Beispiel, dass jetzt irgendwie die eine ein Protokoll haben, wie die US-Telefone.
Genau. Es ist sieben, dieser ganze Kram. Also, dass das überhaupt funktioniert, dass einfach äh,
ne? Das ist einfach quasi so die Basis der der modernen Telekommunikation im Sinne von was modern war mit der äh des letzten Jahrhunderts. Ne? Und.
Das Internet ist eigentlich das der Feind.
Von der ITU. Wenn man das mal so sieht, weil die Telekommunikationskonzerne, wir wissen, was der Beitrag der Telekommunikationskonzerne zum Internet war,
Keiner so, sondern das ist im Wesentlichen, weil das über lange, lange Zeit eher so ein Verhinderungs äh System. Das heißt, die ITU ist einfach organisatorisch inhaltlich ganz anders aufgestellt als,
wie sich diese Internet, ich will jetzt nicht Gemeinde sagen, aber,
Ja, also die Organisation, Personen, Gruppen et cetera, die halt das Netz vorangetrieben und geboren haben, das
Das ist einfach eine andere Geistesherz Herkunft. Wenn jetzt irgendwie China und Russland daherkommen und sagen, man sollte doch aus der ITU ein Aufsichtsgremium fürs Internet machen, dann würde ich sagen.
Alle Alarmlampen an, ja? Also äh das ich meine China, Russland, hallo.
Ja, sie wollen halt einige Funktionen der der ICAN wegnehmen, ne. Also irgendwie äh.
Ja ja, klar.
Also was, was da jetzt also das Problem ist, dass diese diese Debatten der ITU oder diese in der sie sich dann auf die ETRs äh äh da festlegt, die sind wohl natürlich nicht öffentlich und.
Also Internationale Cash. Also diese ITU steht einfach den Nationalstaaten und allen internationalen Strukturen, die nationalstaatlich geprägt sind,
viel, viel, viel näher.
Ja? Und wenn jetzt China und Russland da ankommen und sagen, hier lass mal die ITU das Internet regulieren, dann ist die Sache klar, dann heißt das, wir wollen ein System haben, wo wir,
Sperrverfügung et cetera einfach leichter durchkicken können. Da bin ich jetzt mal ganz unverblümt, das ist das einfach mal offensichtlich. Weil ansonsten.
Ja, das also ist auch tatsächlich hat Russland auch schon so gesagt, dass sie so nettsperren fänden sie auf jeden Fall mal ganz interessant.
Genauso, das finde ich Chinesen ja auch ganz gut, weil die natürlich jetzt auch mittelfristig sehen, dass ihre ihre Firewalls so äh äh mit so einem liberalen Netz halt nicht so ohne Weiteres zu halten.
Ob das so wie Erik Schmidt das jetzt mal letzte Woche wieder ganz weiß sagen äh äh herausposaunt hat so bald fallen wird mit der Firewall, weil das ja äh nicht ginge. Aber ich meine die Voraussagen von Erik Schmidt, also der Schiff äh
würde nicht sagen, dass er jetzt so einen Scheckrekord hat, was so die Voraussage der Zukunft betrifft, ne. Hätten wir jetzt schon mal Steve Jobs fragen müssen, aber ja, ist notte Willy.
Jo, also was hat die ITU Wetz, also um das kurz noch äh rumzureißen? Russland hat irgendwie gesagt, wir wollen Netz sperren und was jetzt also offiziell, sagen sie uns, sie wollen irgendwie internationale Kontrolle für Internetsicherheit und Datenschutz.
Ähm.
Sie wollen äh es erlauben Gebühren für den internationalen Internetverkehr zu verlangen. Also so, hey, äh das war jetzt ein Ferngespräch.
Ja, also genau, das ist genau diese ETO-Denke so.
Äh ähm wirtschaftliche Regeln, Regelungen irgendwie für fürs Peering,
ist er relativ schwammig. Dann sollen sie bestimmte wollen sie die Hoheit über ähm äh die ICAN zum Beispiel haben oder die Hoheit über bestimmte Internet Gouvernance Aufgaben der ICAN?
Genau, wir wollen Domains sperren können.
Ähm dann wollen sie noch ein paar Aufgaben von der äh ITF, also Internet-Engineering Task Force und der Internet-Society, Eishockey, also so alles so alles.
Genau, wir wollen auch gerne nochmal so die HTTP-Standard noch mal um so ein paar äh nette Features äh äh erweitern. Also es ist also wirklich äh okay, alles klar. Da kann man äh und fallen hier so äh noch bezahlen pro Klick am besten, ja?
Ja, irgendwie sowas. Muss man.
Also die wollen sozusagen aus unserem Internet machen, das ist das was sie sagen wollen.
Wir werden es erleben und zwar ähm vom dritten bis vierzehnten Dezember zweitausendzwölf in Dubai.
Da ist nämlich die Weltkonferenz der Internationalen Telekommunikation, WCIT zwölf in Dubai, ja? Äh,
Gibt's jetzt auch schon irgendwie eine längere Seite mit WCIT Leaks
Die heißt äh WCIT Leaks Punkt ORG, äh wo dann alle möglichen Dokumente in allen möglichen Revisionen da drin sind, wo irgendwelche Pläne äh von denen dann äh da drin veröffentlicht werden. Ich bin ganz ehrlich, äh ich hatte jetzt nicht die Zeit, mir das alles im Detail anzuschauen
aber das also ITU hat jetzt auf jeden Fall auch Interesse am Internet ja?
Ansonsten, was also wir hatten ja gesagt, also äh haben wir dann noch. Äh die USA mit ihrem TPP ähm,
und äh dieses CETA bei dem CETA äh da war jetzt, das war jetzt in den letzten Tagen nochmal so in den Medien, weil das nämlich also es betrifft EU und Kanada und wenn man da mal reinschaut
hat man irgendwie so einen, so eine Gutenberg äh,
Zusammenflexerei aus aus Fetzen da drin ja da gibt's also sehr schöne.
Dieses handwerkliche Fehler.
Nee, also so, die haben offensichtlich auf auf etlichen Datenträgern ähm zusammengewusst und dann nicht mehr aus welchem sie jetzt was haben.
Zitatfehler halt.
Einige Zitat.
Manche handwerkliche Fehler, also das kann ja schon mal passieren.
Feder, ohne Frage, ja. Und ähm.
Ja, da da gibt's also eine sehr schöne Zusammenfassung von diesem äh Professor Michael Geist oder der heißt wahrscheinlich Michael Geest oder so,
Michael Guist, Mich Professor Michael Geist aus Kanada, der ähm hat das äh geliebt und äh zusammengefasst und äh ja, also auch da große Sorge, CETA
muss man auch aufpassen. Ähm interessant deshalb, weil weil jetzt wirklich, also ich fand das sehr schön, auch von den Medien, dass sie so irgendwie mit mit direkt fünf Nachfolge,
Problemchen, die Hydra Acta,
ähm jetzt da zum Angriff bläst und das auch sehr schön äh jetzt offensichtlich in die Medien getragen wird und eigentlich jedes dieser Themen jetzt wieder sein eigenes äh Aktivisten
Komitee braucht. Also wer noch Lust hat, irgendwo gegen zu äh aktivisieren.
Gibt auf jeden Fall jetzt kein, kein, kein Mangel an TLAS, ETLAs und äh ETLAC. Ähm oder wie heißen die fünf Buchstabigen Abkürzungen? Ähm.
Ich weiß nicht, was eine fünf Buchstabe Abkürzung ist.
Na du weißt, was ein TLA ist.
Ich googel das mal. Einuare ergibt hier.
Nein, ein TLA ist ein free Dettam.
Okay und du willst jetzt.
Und ein ETLA ist eine vier Buchstabige Abkürzung. An extended TLA. Jetzt habe ich gerade überlegt, wie die fünf Buchstabige Abkürzung heißt, aber das kann ich extended extended heißen, sondern vielleicht äh.
VL, TLA very Long TR oder irgendwie sowas. Na ja, da finden wir noch äh.
Ähm finde ich wirklich ganz toll. Na gut, also äh wir fassen zusammen ähm,
die äh das Acta mag äh jetzt erstmal abgelehnt sein
und jetzt wird natürlich über verschiedene Wege versucht, das irgendwie anders zu regeln. Vor allem versucht man das eben jetzt
aufzudröseln und äh regional durchzuziehen. Ich meine, USA versucht es, was ist das überhaupt für eine Liste? Australien Brudei,
Chili, Malaysia.
Neuseeland, Peru, Singapur, also Transpact Partnership, das ist irgendwie so ein bisschen Südamerika und und Pacific Riedy. Das sind so, was weiß ich, so die Länder, die sich nicht so richtig wehren können oder wie?
Ja, irgendwie so.
Dass man erstmal versucht, darüber äh äh was zu drehen und Kanada und EU na gut.
Also wir dürfen wir dürfen sehr gespannt sein, was da noch alles kommt, aber ähm es ist jetzt auf jeden Fall erstmal ganz interessant, so Akka hat ja erstmal eine Aufmerksamkeit bekommen und ich finde es sehr schön, dass die Medien das jetzt auch so
dann zeigen, ja komm, jetzt kommen jetzt ganz viele andere und große Probleme und alles ist schlimm und Aktivisten, Aktivisten, Aktivisten und Thementhemen.
Ja, ich meine, insofern wird es gut gewesen sein, dass das Acta jetzt mal abgelehnt worden ist,
weil damit irgendwie mal klar geworden ist die Mehrheit ist ja nun auch nennenswert ne? Also vierhundertachtundsiebzig,
zu neununddreißig bei hundertfünfundsechzig Enthaltungen, also selbst wenn die hundertfünfundsechzig noch dafür gestimmt hätten, wäre es ja schon deutlich gewesen.
Zweihundert zu äh.
Bisschen mehr als zweihundert, zweihundertvier, zu vierhundertachtundsiebzig. Das ist schon schon ein deutliches Zeichen und da kann man irgendwie klarmachen, hier ähm da gibt es einfach eine ganz klare politische Ablehnung gegen diesen generellen Trend. Ja,
wenn das jetzt nicht vielleicht die Motivation jedes einzelnen Parlamentariers gewesen ist, ne, so grundsätzlich dagegen abzustimmen,
aber wenn es eben so eine deutliche Abstimmung ist und nicht was ganz knapp ist, dann merkt man schon,
Dass ähm zumindest weite Teile hier wirklich auf wenig Gegenliebe gestoßen sind und in dem Moment, wo eben genau diese Teile,
In anderen Verpackungen daherkommen, dann äh äh müsste es auch möglich sein, dafür wieder Medienaufmerksamkeit zu erzeugen. Du bist bei uns.
Wollen wir's hoffen.
Medienaufmerksamkeit hat äh auch bekommen, dass Meldegesetz, es ist ja eigentlich, es ist ja jetzt gerade das große Thema.
Eine eine eine großartige Geschichte, eigentlich verzerrlich, ja. Ähm und zwar beschließt der Bundestag,
Eine Reform des Meldegesetzes am Tage, ich glaube sogar während oder kurz bevor.
Des Spiels Deutschland gegen Italien.
Während des Spiels Deutschland gegen Italien, wo Italien glamourös äh gegen Deutschland gesiegt hat,
Ähm und irgendwann da abends, als die als dieses Spiel dann da stattfindet, ähm,
sitzen da noch so ein paar Hansel im Bundestag und winken in siebenundfünfzig Sekunden. Es gibt ja den Videobeweis, ja, also Parlaments-TV, dann kannst du den Stoppuhr dran halten. Äh äh in siebenundfünfzig Sekunden geht das Ding durch komplett von
Ja, was haben wir hier noch? Zack, zack, zack, Feierabend. Jo, tschau. Ähm.
Vor allem zweite und dritte Lesung, ja, also das ist geil.
Durch alles durch. Und jetzt wird's aber keiner gewesen sein. Das war sehr schön, ja. Es ist also die, das Gesetz zur Fortentwicklung des Meldewesens. Ähm das musste irgendwie langsam mal gemacht werden.
Bevor wir vielleicht auf das Gesetz selber kommen. Ja. Und noch mal diesen diesen Modus vielleicht nochmal kurz äh ins Auge nehmen, weil da ist natürlich viel drüber gelächelt worden. Ist aber schon auch eine gewisse Realität, ne. Ich meine, wir haben jetzt,
äh ein Parlament, was in seiner Arbeit primär sich eben über die Arbeit in Ausschüssen definiert,
Gibt's, glaube ich, auch einen Begriff, für die habe ich jetzt gerade nicht parat. So, ne, auch wenn die Wahrnehmung immer so dieses ist, na ja, wir haben ja ein Parlament, damit da geredet wird,
heißt ja reden, ne. Nur so viel wird da halt immer nicht geredet, sondern in diesen siebenundfünfzig Sekunden wurden ja auch diverse Reden,
gehalten, also nicht wirklich, sondern sie wurden, wie es so schön heißt, zu Protokoll gegeben,
Ich weiß überhaupt nicht, wie das läuft. Ich meine, setz dich dann wirklich da jemand hin, schreibt irgendwie übern Tag eine Rede.
Die schreiben ja die Mitarbeiter.
Ja ja klar, aber ich meine, das ist ja Arbeitszeit, die da äh drauf geht. Es muss ja auch geschrieben werden. Ich meine, gut, vielleicht haben die da auch mittlerweile die modernen Cut und Paste äh äh Methodiken äh ebenmaliger äh äh Ministerer.
Schreib mal was zu.
Ja, so in etwa, ne, also man man hat da wahrscheinlich auch so einen Floskel äh äh Baukasten,
generell Scheiße findet und überhaupt, damit man dann später irgendwie sagen kann, naja, ich war ja dagegen und hier guckt mal meine Rede und da stand ja auch alles drin. Nur dass diese Rede eben so nie gehalten wurde, sondern sie wird dann eben zu Protokoll
das heißt, man legt dann da so einen Zettel dahin und dann hat man quasi so ein Attachment äh einer E-Mail, was ja, nie einer liest. So,
Und dann waren ja die paar Hanseln, war ja dann sozusagen immer noch interessanterweise immer noch proportional zu den Kräfteverhältnissen oder im Wesentlichen proportional zu den Kräfteverhältnissen zwischen Regierung und Opposition vertreten. Also wie bestellt und wahrscheinlich,
Ist es in gewisser Hinsicht auch bestellt, also es wird quasi in der parlamentarischen Arbeit,
dann dafür gesorgt, dass trotz eines solchen Spieles eben, damit da eine Abstimmung stattfinden kann, die entsprechenden Vertreter da sind, aber wären jetzt mehr von der Opposition da gewesen,
dann weiß ich dich. Hätten wir, wenn die dann wieder freiwillig rausgegangen oder.
Die anderen dann noch ein paar geholt, also irgendwie also das ist ja so ein anerkanntes Spiel, ja, dass man quasi den Bundestag,
In so einer Art ähm soll man sagen.
Bisschen so eine kleine Schlumpfparade da äh äh macht, ja, was so die richtigen Vertreter, die man so braucht, sind sie irgendwie dabei, ist so ein Mini-Bundestag.
Und der beschließt dann das Gesetz so, als wären eigentlich alle da. Also es ist mehr so eine Simulation.
Ja
Ne
Emotionen, so eine VM. Und äh in der das dann so läuft. So und dann, dann wird dann halt beschlossen, aber man merkt auch, irgendwie weiß keiner eigentlich, worum's geht.
Wurde dann am Ende irgendwas beschlossen, in der dann halt.
Ja, deswegen gibt's da einen.
Den letzten Metern noch eine Änderung äh angebracht wurden, die sich wohl auch nie jemand angeschaut hat oder ja, weiß nicht.
Ja, also es ist, die wurden da jetzt einfach mal kalt erwischt. Ähm.
Müssen wir nochmal sagen, was eigentlich wirklich genau passiert ist. Also es wurde ein Meldegesetz beschlossen, was über lange, lange Zeit vorbereitet wurde und in der Form, wie's aber beschlossen wurde,
existierte diese Vorlage aber noch gar nicht so lange. Weißt du, wann diese letzte Änderung, die umstrittene stattfand?
Ist mir in dem Falle jetzt ähm relativ egal. Also es gibt ja müssen wir mal überlegen, es es gibt ja eigentlich, also was was sind jetzt überhaupt die Änderungen, die da
gefunden haben so. Also sie sie haben gesagt, wir müssen jetzt irgendwie wir haben eine äh zweitausendsechs eine Förderalismusreform gemacht und in der wurde gesagt, wir wollen
Melderecht hauptsächlich von den Ländern auf den Bund übertragen. Das heißt, der Bund muss sich darum kümmern, weniger Ländersache.
Ähm und das Erste, was sie gesagt haben, das erste Problem, was sie jetzt meinten, lesen zum äh lösen zu müssen, war,
dass auf einmal insbesondere in Berlin oder in in größeren Städten. Ähm Eltern auf einmal anfangen.
Sich überall äh in in bestimmten Bezirken zu melden, damit ihr Kind auf bestimmte Schulen gehen kann, weil sie in anderen Stadtteilen nicht zur Schule gehen wollen. So, äh Hintergrund, also Grundschule.
Und was sie jetzt meinten, da müssen wir wieder einführen, die Vermieterbescheinigung. Das heißt, man äh soll also, wenn man dann zum ähm zum Bürgeramt geht und sagt, äh guten Tag, ich wohne jetzt da und da.
Dann war das früher immer so, dass sie gesagt haben, ja okay, sag mal noch irgendwie vorderes Hinterhaus oder so und dann ja, ja, ja, haste gesagt und bist gegangen. Konnte man sich sehr leicht eine Meldeadresse besorgen,
ähm oder kann man auch heute noch so. Und die wollten also jetzt, dass sie dann wieder eine Vermieterbescheinigung geben muss. Das heißt, dann muss irgendwie äh der muss den Mietvertrag mitbringen oder der Vermieter muss sagen, ja der ist auch tatsächlich hier oder was auch immer. Das war so das Erste. Ähm,
Und dann haben sie äh gesagt, okay,
Es gibt ja diese Maßnahme der Meldegerister Melde Meldegerister, Melderegister Auskunft und da können also
Firmen quasi beim Melderegister anfragen. Und man kann bei seiner Anmeldung sagen, okay, ich möchte, dass sie es dürfen oder ich möchte, dass sie es nicht dürfen. So und was sie
was sie jetzt haben, was ursprünglich verlangt wurde oder was momentan, glaube ich, auch noch der Stand ist, ist, dass man ähm dabei,
ein hat, das heißt man muss Häkchen machen, damit sie es dürfen.
Und äh nicht man muss ein Häkchen machen, damit sie es nicht dürfen. Ja, und jetzt also in dieser neuen Regelung ist es also ein Opt-out, das heißt, man muss dem widersprechen
es ist die, dass es nicht so ist. Ist schon mal besonders kritisch, weil ähm die meisten so was eben nicht lesen, das heißt, damit erschließt du immer so ungefähr sechsundsechzig Prozent äh die Ford Click User so,
und,
Dann bekommt der äh in diesem Gesetz, der der Bürger das Recht der Übermittlung der Daten zu widersprechen, ja, durch diese Optout-Regelung, aber und jetzt kommt's, das gilt nicht.
Als Recht zu widersprechen gilt nicht, wenn die Daten ausschließlich zur Bestätigung oder Berechtigung bereits vorhandener Daten verwendet werden,
Das heißt, ich kann widersprechen, dass irgendeiner da anruft und sagt äh oder meldest du ausgerufen hat, sag mal, wer Linus Neumann ist, wo der wohnt. Ich kann aber nicht widersprechen, wenn einer sagt, hör mal, ich habe hier
Linus Neumann, irgendwie so Daten, der wohnt irgendwie da und da, ich habe den Eindruck, das ist falsch. Ähm sag mal die richtigen Daten.
Und das vor allem auf Bundesebene dann. Also man muss sich nicht beim richtigen Anwohnermeldeamt melden, sondern es geht ja dann hier um eine zentrale Auskunft. Sprich, die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass man die.
Ich bin mir also äh ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob das eine zentrale oder eine äh ob man das immer noch beim Land machen würde oder bei also ich denke, ich gehe eigentlich davon aus, dass du das trotzdem noch bei der jeweiligen Behörde machen müsstest und nicht eine eine allgemeine.
Das heißt, es wurde nur dann funktionieren, wenn man schon auch beim richtigen Amt auftaucht.
Ist halt die Frage, ob die dann nicht irgendwann sagen können, also da muss schon irgendeines haben, wo der mal war, ja. Gehe ich jetzt mal von aus, da da weiß ich nicht genau, wo man da diese Anfragen stellen kann. Soweit ich das verstehe, ist es aber nicht so, dass es ein deutsches äh Melderregister gibt, wo alle drin sind. Da
glaube ich, dass die Datenschutz äh Regelung dem äh nicht äh entsprechen.
So, aber Problem ist also, dass ich jetzt dadurch äh also wer nachträglich illegal erlangte, ähm Daten haben möchte.
Oder wer nachträglich die prüfen möchte, also oder man gibt einfach mal eine falsche an und kriegt dann die Richtige beantwortet. Ähm dann,
ist diese gesamte Regelung ja eigentlich umsonst, ja? Also es ist schon mal ein Opt-Out, was schon mal schlecht ist und der nützt nichts, wenn die Leute die die Daten schon einmal haben. Das heißt, wer meine Daten einmal hat
darf mich weiterverfolgen, wenn ich umziehe, obwohl ich das eigentlich nicht möchte, ja. Also es geht.
Oder zumindest er meint, dass er die richtige habe, hat aber eigentlich eine Falsche. Denkt sich einfach eine aus.
Er gibt einfach absichtlich. Ich denke, dass das so möglich wäre, ja. Ähm mit anderen Worten, da ähm.
Oder scrapt die sich halt aus irgendwelchen Impressums raus und dann.
Und hält die dann halt, ja, also man muss halt einfach nur sagen, ich habe die hier schon.
Zumindest kann man auch dann falsche oder geratene Adressen daraufhin überprüfen. Genau. Ob sie richtig sind.
Und das ist da kann man dann da gibt's eben keine Möglichkeit mehr zu widersprechen, ja?
So und jetzt dann ging das irgendwie los und dann wurde auf einmal dann äh gab es äh Medieninteresse daran und dann sagte irgendwie äh Manuel Hüverlin von der FDP, der Vorsitzende der AG IT und Netzpolitik äh
Wir haben das Recht der betroffenen Person einer automatisierten Melderregisterauskunft zu widersprechen, gestrichen. Bevor hier wieder das Geschrei aus der Opposition kommt, die Entscheidung war richtig
Da hat er sich dann aber, glaube ich, relativ bald äh anders überlegt, weil ähm,
dann irgendwie meldeten sich äh Tido Weichert und sogar EU-Justizkomissarin Vivian Reding, alle haben gesagt, dass das irgendwie alles totaler Quatsch ist, was äh was da entschieden wurde und alle waren
also die Kritik war groß und dann wollte es wieder keiner gewesen sein. Also Linke, Grüne, SPD waren sowieso dagegen. Ähm,
das Ei gelegt haben irgendwie CDU, CSU und FDP. Und dann sagte ähm.
Dann stand halt irgendwie Horst Seehofer auf der Bühne und sagte, ja, äh nee, äh können wir so nicht machen und gleichzeitig
statt woanders die Leute von der CDU auf der Bühne und sagten, ja ja die wir haben uns äh wir haben gedacht, komm wir streiten uns jetzt nicht mit der CSU, die wollten das halt unbedingt so geändert haben
Also haben wir es mal durchgewunken und die FDP stellte sich erst hin und schrie, ja hier
und äh musste sich dann wahrscheinlich auch erstmal überlegen, ähm was sie da verbockt haben, soweit ich das verstanden habe, hat dann äh Justizministerin Leuthäuser Schnarrenberger dann auch gesagt hätte, ja so irgendwie alles nicht sein könnte und wegen liberal und sonst was Partei
ja? Und dann trat gestern ähm der äh Steffen Seibert auf die äh in Erscheinung.
Der Regierungssprecher.
Regierungssprecher und sagte, ja, ähm das wäre jetzt alles nicht so, nicht so gut gelaufen und ähm,
Bundesregierung hoffe also eindeutig auf Nachbesserung des Gesetzes im Bundesrat. Das ist nämlich ein Beschluss äh also ein ein ein zustimmungspflichtiges Gesetz, das heißt das muss jetzt nochmal durch den Bundesrat.
Der Bundesrat muss das jetzt durchnicken. Und jetzt hat quasi Bundesregierung mit ihrer Mehrheit im Bundestag ein Gesetz beschlossen,
Irgendwie während der Fußball-WM da unten irgendwie äh um zwanzig Uhr noch was, wo dann der Einzige, der immer noch nach wie vor super findet, ist irgendwie hier äh Friedrich,
äh Innenminister Friedrich, der sagt, ja ähm wer das mal genau liest, das ist eine Verbesserung des Datenschutzes. Okay, der hat auch den Entwurf ähm geschrieben, also der kommt vom Innenministerium. Ja, also der.
Dass diese Änderung es von dem Uhl und von dieser Gisela Pils durchgebracht worden.
Wenn du das, wenn das so deine Informationen sind, dann ist das so. Ich habe mich um den.
Meine Information, aber ich weiß nicht, ob sie stimmen.
Ich habe mich um die in also ich habe mich darum, wie die Änderung da jetzt genau reingekommen ist, gar nicht so interessiert. Äh weil äh entscheidend ist, was da entschlossen wird, ja und.
Das sowieso, ja.
Ne, aber jetzt, also Regierungssprecher Steffen Seibert stellt sich hin und sagt, ja, was wir da, was unsere äh Regierung da im Bundestag hat, entscheiden lassen,
enthält ohne Zweifelfehler und ähm äh wir hoffen, dass der Bundesrat das jetzt korrigiert.
Fällt dir ja gar nichts mehr zu ein.
Nee, ist geil.
Ne? Und sagt mir, ist auch gut so. Es ist wahrscheinlich auch gut, dass das so beschlossen wurde, ja? Vom Bundestag, damit der Bundesrat das jetzt ähm.
Douglas Adams so schön schrieb, woraufhin der Mensch dann auch noch bewies, dass Schwarz gleich weiß ist und wenige Minuten später auf einem Zebrastreifen ums Leben kam.
Ja
und nun mal jetzt die Dimension der Logik der Zelebration hier.
Klarzumachen. Also äh ja, eine Posse. Ich sagte es schon, es ist ähm wirklich interessant und zeigt natürlich auch wieder mal sehr schön.
Wie hilflos äh teilweise agiert wird. Ich meine, das ist jetzt sehr einfach, da auf die äh Abgeordneten einzuschlagen, ja?
Oder zu fordern, dass ja die Opposition ja dieses und jenes hätte tun können und wenn ihr dann mehr Leute hättet und so weiter, ja, aber so sind da nun mal die Rituale und diese sind natürlich auch ähm,
alle Opfer quasi des des äh äh herrschenden Systems. Ich meine, stell dir vor, du bist jetzt keine Ahnung, äh wirst jetzt bei der nächsten Wahl als SPD,
Abgeordneter von Landkreis äh Hintertupffing äh da äh reingewählt, kommst dann irgendwie in diesen Betrieb, ja, dann ist erstmal hier große äh Fraktionssitzung und dann wird hier erstmal
vorne und hinten gesagt, wie der Hase so läuft. Ja, ich meine, da stellst du dich jetzt nicht äh als der Revolutionär hin und sagst, na ja, äh,
Ja, äh wir machen das jetzt mal ganz anders. So schnell passt sich das da eben nicht an. Auf der anderen Seite sind sie auch da irgendwie auch in so einer Realitätsblase äh gefangen, wo man sich eben fragen muss, muss das eigentlich so laufen?
Also die die Idee der oder die die Idee der parlamentarischen Demokratie krank ja eigentlich heutzutage ähm.
Hauptsächlich an ähm.
Also einmal gab's ja so diese Erfahrung aus Weimarer Republik, wo das ja alles noch so ein bisschen mehr äh wir reden alle und so weiter ging und sie sie also eigentlich die die Wurzel allen übelst ist ja so ein ein ähm Kompetenz,
Und ein äh Massenproblem, also ein ein ein eine ähm,
Einmal das Problem, dass sie kompetent sein müssen in den Bereichen, die in über die in den Themenbereichen über die entschieden wird. Und andererseits, dass es zu viele Entscheidungen sind, ja. Ähm.
Das heißt, was,
Was sich also, wenn man jetzt immer davon ausgeht, da sind äh gewählte Volksvertreter, die sollen etwas durchdiskutieren am Ende die die beste den besten Ausgleich aller Interessen.
Finden, wobei ja die Theorie des Parlamentarismus eigentlich sagt, dass da nicht der Ausgleich aller Interessen, sondern der Ausgleich der Meinungen,
stattfindet, ja? Und das dann glücklich quasi so aus der, aus dem Universum, der Meinungen sich als äh als Ausgleich dann die die Wahrheit als beste Lösung herauskristallisiert, ja? Also,
der Konsens ähm so aber okay das.
Wahrheit für dich da jetzt mal nicht sprechen.
Na ja, also ich will, also als ähm,
Weit ist das, über das sich alle einig sind. Also, also okay, sagen wir nicht Wahrheit. Sagen wir so, der Konsens, aber quasi so das Beste. Ja, die beste Meinung,
der Wettkampf der Meinung in so einem liberalen äh System, wo man eben davon ausgeht, jeder hat äh kann gleich viel sagen und das Einzige, was dann noch zählen kann, ist, was wer das Beste sagt.
Ja. Und ähm das ist natürlich sowieso schon mal von Meinungen braucht man da überhaupt nicht zu reden, sondern es ist knallhart Interessen, ja. Schon mal schon mal irgendwie Problem Nummer eins, was was diese parlamentarische Demokratie hat. Da stellt sich stellen sich nur wenige Menschen hin, die etwas aus einer äh aus
aus Überzeugung äh also da sind wenige Multimillionäre aus der SPD, die aus Überzeugung ähm
in der SPD, die aus Überzeugung für soziale Gerechtigkeit kämpfen, mag auch sein, eher äh bist du da aber äh und vertrittst äh ein,
Bevölkerungsgruppe, die konkrete Interessen hat. Sondern das heißt, du hast, du hast einen Wettkampf der Interessen, statt der Meinung, du hast dann ähm,
ganz, ganz viele enorm detaillierte ähm Themengebiete, über die zu entscheiden ist, zu denen nicht alle Kompetenz haben können.
Alle dort vertretenen Personen. Was was ist die Folge daraus? Man nimmt erstens, macht man irgendwelche Ausschüsse, ja? Der eine ist in dem Ausschuss, der andere ist in dem Ausschuss und wenn du nicht in dem Ausschuss bist, dann bist du eher auf so einer Stimmvieh
Position. Gleichzeitig reicht aber teilweise selbst in den Ausschüssen aufgrund der Arbeitsüberlastung
die Zeit nicht aus, um sich da eine vernünftige Kompetenz anzueignen. Das heißt, dann fangen wir an und holen sich ähm.
Beratung, Experten, ja, dass es da, da entsteht quasi das Feld des Lobbyismus, ja, dass man sagt,
stell dir mal vor, du hast gerade gesagt, ich bin irgendwie aus aus Buxtehude irgendwie in in äh Lande im Bundestag und dann soll ich auf einmal irgendwie, sagen wir mal, irgendeine Gesetz äh zur Förderung oder äh
der Solarenergie oder so
betreffen. Ja natürlich muss ich dann erstmal überhaupt wissen, was ist, kann ich überhaupt sagen, OK zweitausendzwanzig haben wir einhundert Prozent Energieversorgung durch Solarenergie. Ja, ist zum Beispiel jetzt in dem Fall nicht möglich
Müssen ja Leute kommen, die mir das erklären. So und letztendlich hast du dann also ähm,
Alle möglichen Ausschüsse, alle möglichen äh Interessenvertreter und keiner in dem ganzen Laden hat mir überhaupt einen Überblick in irgendeinem Bereich. Und wer den wirklich, wer wer sich in einem Bereich enorm vertieft,
Personen, die in der Politik Karriere machen möchte, ähm riskiert bei dieser Vertiefung,
aufs falsche Pferd zu setzen, auf ein Thema, was nicht äh, was nicht besonders relevant ist, ja? Ähm,
und dann einfach unterzugehen und deswegen äh keine politische Karriere machen zu können. Ähm.
Und was was wir das zweite Wasser riskiert, äh ja, dann in anderen Bereichen,
sich nicht mal mehr den Überblick verschaffen zu können und dort Fehler machen zu können. Das heißt, dieses gesamte System Parlamentarier zu sein, ähm ist eigentlich als Phänomen betrachtet, hat das nichts mehr mit dem zu tun, was da eigentlich mal abgehen sollte.
Also was man, was man sich eigentlich mal vorgestellt hat, ne, dass da dass da äh ja diskutiert wird. Also ist ja auch so eine, ist ja zum Beispiel.
Redest ja von einem Ideal, ja? Äh ich ich bezweifle, dass dieses Ideal jemals erreicht wurde, ja.
Nee, natürlich nicht, aber dieses Ideal ist die Rechtfertigung unseres kompletten politischen Systems. Damit rechtfertigen, dass wir rechtfertigen wir, dass wir das alles überhaupt machen.
Und wenn du ähm also ich meine, ich möchte, ich möchte,
Tag in der Geschichte der der Bundesrepublik Deutschland oder von mir aus auch der Weimarer Republik sehen, wo irgendwie im im Parlament eine Diskussion stattfindet, einer eine Rede hält und dann der andere sagt, Mensch, das hast du recht.
Da habe ich noch nicht drüber nachgedacht. Da hast du Recht, muss ich mir noch überlegen, lass mich lass mal kurz gucken, vielleicht können wir uns.
Vermisse ich auch in der Bloßphäre bisweil.
Das ist einfach.
Aber das ist also äh die Idee Liberalismus Prinzip, ne, also ähm,
Funktioniert so nicht, ne? Und dann kommt natürlich, will ich jetzt gar nicht so, so, so, so stark vertiefen, aber kommt irgendwann die Frage, was ist es denn, was da passiert? Wenn, wenn dieser, wenn wir davon ausgehen, wenn wir das mit, mit ähm,
Mit der Theorie äh
das eben durch Liberalismus, also das äh alle fangen gleich an und das, das, das, das, das stärkste und durchsetzungsfähigste und vernünftigste setzt sich durch. Wenn das offensichtlich nicht der Fall ist, wenn viele andere Grundvoraussetzungen für das, was wir da in diesem Parlamenten machen, nicht
erfüllt sind? Was ist es dann, was wir da machen? Und da finde ich so einen, so ein äh Vorkommnis wie mit diesem Meldegesetz
echt
super. Und auch diese diese Reaktion dann, dass ich ernsthaft, also dass sich der der Regierungssprecher entblödet und sagt, schön, was weder äh entschieden haben, das ist natürlich ganz klar, dass da nochmal der Bundesrat drüber gehen muss. Ja, also ich meine, die treffen ja auch am laufenden Band Gesetz.
Ich meine, der ist ein ein Regierungssprecher, ich meine, es kann kein Wunder, dass sich da jemand vom ZDF geholt haben, also das ist äh äh verstehst du, der, der, der verkauft ja halt auch noch die Scheiße irgendwie als äh äh als ein Topping für äh für dein Dessert,
Das äh ist ja nun vollkommen klar. Da muss man sich auch nicht groß drüber aufregen.
Auch nicht, ich will jetzt auch nicht die große Diskussion an dieser Stelle starten, auch wenn das natürlich gleich wieder so ein so ein Unterthema ist, was ich äh hier aufdrängt. Ich denke, man muss schon darüber nachdenken.
Öffentlich in der in der politischen Diskussion, wie man solche Prozesse verbessern kann. Also ohne Häme da jetzt auch drauf zu schlagen, weil ich denke auch aus unserem Gespräch ist schnell klar geworden, es gibt eine akute Überforderung der Abgeordneten,
Leute, denen wir die Macht delegieren, ja, auf denen unsere ganzen Erwartungen, Hoffnungen, Ansprüche liegen, ja,
wir gerne mal komplett.
Soll ich sagen, äh einmal durchranten bis nichts mehr übrig bleibt, ja oder auch vielleicht mal äh selten, aber auch
in den Himmel loben, wenn sie sich mal
für was entschlossen haben, was man selber gut findet. Diese Leute sind eigentlich überfordert. Und auch mit ihren ein oder zwei Mitarbeitern, die sie dann äh dann noch finanzieren können, sind sie auch überfordert.
Das hat auch was damit zu tun, dass eben so ein mangelhaftes Delegationssystem gibt, weil es Delegationssystem derzeit besteht im Wesentlichen auf,
Ich trage die Fraktionsmeinung mit. Das ist ja eigentlich das Ding. Und das führt dazu, dass eben solche Entscheidungen.
Eigentlich nur an sehr wenigen Stellen wirklich aktiv mitgestaltet werden. Klar kannst du in der Ausschussarbeit über einen längeren Zeitraum versuchen das eine zu erarbeiten,
Wenn du da eben kompetent bist und wenn du da auch Durchschlagskraft hast, ja? Aber so als Hinterbänkler dürft's wahrscheinlich schon äh deutlich schwieriger werden.
Und wenn's eben in irgendeiner Form Starts äh Raison, Partei-Rason, Fraktionsraison gibt, dann kannst du dich eigentlich dem Ganzen nur noch,
unterordnen und das Ganze drückt sich dann eben wunderbar in solchen Kasperle, Theatersituationen aus, wo sie da irgendwie in siebenundfünfzig Sekunden
wer das Video noch nicht gesehen hat, das muss man sich wirklich mal anschauen, ja? Also so erste Lesung jetzt wird hier mit Hand hochheben, irgendwie abgestimmt, in der zweiten Lesung muss man dann aufstehen, ich hab nicht verstand
was der qualitative Unterschied zwischen Aufstehen und äh Handheben ist. Ja, aber offensichtlich sind es beides irgendwie so valide Wege. Und wenn man sich das so anguckt, dann dann hat man wirklich das Gefühl, dass sie da alle sowieso
Handpuppen irgendwie, ja, also als ob da sozusagen unter
und unter dem Parlamentsboden irgendwie so zwei Riesen sitzen, die irgendwie äh da quasi die Fraktionen hoch äh aufstehen lassen oder klassischerweise würde man vielleicht jetzt hier äh Marionitten als Assoziation wählen.
Ja? Aber ich will denen das jetzt selber, diesen Akteuren da konkret so gar nicht,
vorwerfen, die tun einfach nur das, was von ihnen erwartet wird, was von der Fraktion, von den Regeln des äh Parlamentarischen Systems in Deutschland erwartet wird und man müsste eigentlich genau von diesen Regeln eigentlich befreien.
Die gibt's ja, also die meisten Regeln, die du da jetzt so annimmst, die gibt's ja eigentlich gar nicht. Also die müssen sich ja nicht an ihre Fraktionen halten. Das ist ja jetzt zum Beispiel, dass das nächste Problem, ne?
Gibt's das nicht auf dem Papier.
Sie haben aber genau, sie sind aber alles natürlich Dinge, die sich eingeschliffen haben, weil man.
Immer schon so gemacht hat.
Weil der Laden auch sonst wahrscheinlich nicht funktionieren.
Na ja, wir machen mal irgendwann da äh gerne nochmal sehr viel mehr Parlamentarismuskritik. Ich habe da mal sehr viel zu gelesen,
ähm gibt's ganz interessante Veröffentlichungen zu. Es gibt auch vor allem wenn man also.
Schöne Debatten, das können wir uns mal aufheben für ein Lokbuchnetzpolitik Spezial. Sommergarten.
Ja, machen wir mal. Karl Schmidt, Karl Schmidt, bester äh Parlamentarismuskritiker, leider dann irgendwann hat das alles in den Nazis gemündet, aber machen wir mal, machen wir mal.
Immer wirklich mal so ein Sommer Sommerevent machen. Setzen wir uns schön irgendwie hier so wie es Fernsehgarten, weißt du?
Mit Pfeife, ich möchte dabei Pfeife rauchen. Zum Ohrensessel, keine Ahnung, jedenfalls, ist mir egal. So eine.
Eine Pfeife. Bambus oder Glas?
So eine lange äh nicht.
Ja, ja.
Also so wie Gandalf oder so. Ähm aber ich wollte auch ähm.
Du kleiner Zauberer, du.
Ich ich wollte nur ich wollte noch was Schönes erzählen. Ich wollte noch was Schönes erzählen. Ich habe nämlich mir war nämlich nichts äh zu teuer. Wir wir wechseln jetzt mal das Thema. Du kannst mal hier den Knopf drücken mit Themenwechsel. Äh Wikidex hat ja wieder was veröffentlicht. Ähm und zwar wollen sie jetzt.
Herr ist ja immer noch äh in der Botschaft, ne.
Immer noch in der Botschaft.
Jahr die Sache entscheidet sich binnen von Minuten und tatsächlich passiert nix.
Hängt da jetzt rum. Jetzt hat er irgendwie jetzt ich äh,
wir warten mal bis zur nächsten großen Meldung. Jetzt hat er irgendwie gesagt, der kommt da raus, wenn sie ihm garantiert, dass sie nicht in die USA schickt. Was auch immer. Ähm,
Genau, also wichtigste ist aber eigentlich nur die kurze Menge, zweieinhalb Millionen E-Mails von syrischen Ministerien, wollen sie jetzt veröffentlichen aus dem Zeitraum zweitausendsechs bis zweitausendzwölf? Vielleicht ist das so eine Schamoffenoffensive gegen die äh an die USA, ne, dass wir dass sie sagen so, ja, wir sind nicht nur antiamerikanisch, sondern,
wir hauen auch auf Syrien drauf. Bis jetzt habe ich viel mehr davon nicht gelesen als ähm.
Diese Veröffentlichung. Äh es gab dann noch irgendwie die Feststellung, dass irgendeine italienische IT-Firma etwas an Syrien geliefert hatte im Tetrafunkbereich. Ähm,
Ja, aber bis jetzt war da noch nicht so der große Skandal. Ich denke mal, der wird dann hoffentlich die Tage noch kommen. Also hat wieder was veröffentlicht.
Aber was ich eigentlich erzählen wollte, ich habe mich nämlich mit schwedischen Freunden unterhalten und äh zwar zu dem Thema, dass äh,
wie jetzt so die Sache mit Julian ist, ja? Und die haben gesagt,
Also ich habe sie dann mal gefragt, so wie wie sie so diese Wahrscheinlichkeit einschätzen, dass Schweden den ähm ausliefern würde. Und dann haben sie gesagt, diese Wahrscheinlichkeit ist null.
In anderen Auslieferungsverfahren schon irgendwie riesigen Krawall hatten, wo es einfach nur um äh sage ich mal Normalsterbliche äh Asylbewerber oder so ging und nicht um irgendwelche ähm Popstars,
wie Julian Assange einer ist und ich hab sie dann immer so nach ihrer Meinung gefragt und die haben gesagt sie sind quasi als schwedische Bürger unglaublich enttäuscht,
Verärgert über Julian Assange, weil die unglaublich stolz waren, dass er da in ihren, in ihr Land damals ja eigentlich geflüchtet ist. Ja, also der hat sich ja in Schweden aufgehalten, weil er sich da eben.
Im äh demokratischen Rahmen irgendwie besonders sicher gefühlt hat mit seinen Veröffentlichungen, sind unglaublich enttäuscht, dass er ähm.
Diesem Land nun öffentlich die ganze Zeit.
Die äh unterstellt, dass es ihnen ausliefern würde an die USA und dass es einen Plot gegen ihn führt.
Das fand ich sehr, fand ich äh eine sehr äh interessante Auffassung, die ich hier nochmal weitergeben wollte, dass sie also sagten, sie sind sie fühlen sich eigentlich beleidigt.
Ja
Das kann ich auch sehr gut nachvollziehen.
Haben wir den WikiLeaks Teil damit eigentlich schon beendet, weil dann kann ich das gleich sozusagen die Debatte in ein anderes Thema überführen. Das war vielleicht auch noch hier aufnehmen sollten.
Das habe ich mir auch gerade gedacht. Du meinst, ähm the Peter.
Peter, genau. Ja. Da gibt es einen, also Peter, Peter Sunde,
Ja, auch ein Popstar auf äh seine Art, ja, vielleicht nicht ganz so wie Julian Assange, aber spielt in einer ähnlichen Liga und auch die ganze Geschichte spielt in Schweden, Pirate Bay, äh kennen das. Wir haben das Thema ja auch schon ein paar Mal
aufgegriffen und es gab ja vor einiger Zeit schon eben diesen,
gegen oder wo sozusagen gegen verschiedene Vertreter von Prozess geführt wurde, der letzten Endes mit einer Verurteilung,
Unter anderem von Peter Sunde äh endete. So und,
dass es jetzt alles auch vom Verfassungsgericht nochmal im letzten Schritt sozusagen der Widerspruch äh abgelehnt worden
und äh im Prinzip ist das Ganze jetzt rechtskräftig und es kann jetzt jederzeit
dazu kommen, dass sie ihn eben tatsächlich für ein Jahr einknasten und vor allem ist damit verbunden, eine Bestrafung äh in Höhe von elf Millionen Euro an Schadensersatzzahlungen, an, na ja,
Anrechteinhaber, die halt haben glaubhaft machen können, dass sie eben einen solchen Schaden auch erlitten haben, dadurch, dass bei Pirat Bay irgendwelche Movies äh gesiedelt wurden oder beziehungsweise,
gar nicht mal gesiedelt wurden, sondern eben getrackt wurden, beziehungsweise dieses Verzeichnis existierte.
Jetzt hat Peter Sohne da einen längeren Blogpost zu geschrieben auf Schwedisch wiederum,
und äh der äh Rick äh Falk Winge, der Gründer von der Pirate Party, also der Piratenpartei,
äh Schweden hat sich die Mühe gemacht und diesen Blogpost komplett auf Englisch übersetzt und wenn ihr nix zu diesen,
habt gerade, sonst irgendwie, dann empfehle ich euch ausdrücklich diesen Text.
Hatte da auch schon mal ähm auf Twitter drauf verwiesen, denn die Zusammenfassung, wie es bei diesem abgelaufen ist, das,
lässt einem schon so ein bisschen das Blut in den Adern äh gefrieren und weißt du, wenn wir jetzt über darüber reden, dass Julian Assange nicht die Hoffnung hat, äh im im Kontext
ähm der schwedischen Gesetzgebung da richtig,
behandelt zu werden, dann muss man sich eigentlich nur den Bericht von Peter Sonder anschauen und dann kriegt man sehr schnell das Gefühl, dass das sehr wohl eine sehr reale Bedrohung ist. Denn obwohl das schwedische System an sich dafür bekannt war, immer, ja,
eben sehr liberal zu agieren und auch sehr rechtsstaatskonform zu agieren, ist das hier einfach im Falle von Peter Sunde ganz offenbar.
Vor die Runde gegangen, das kann man jetzt echt nicht anders sagen. Also sich anschaut, ich habe jetzt mir leider keine ähm,
Richtigen Notizen äh äh gemacht, aber im Wesentlichen,
werden ihm ja äh Sachen vorgeworfen, die überhaupt nicht belegt sind, ja, also unter anderem wird ihm vorgeworfen, er habe einen Rechner aufgesetzt, äh der ein Lot Balancer ist
so, ja? Im Rahmen von eben diesen Vorwürfen, er hätte eben auch aktiv unterstützt
Dieser Rechner ist irgendwie von dem Provider aufgesetzt worden. Dieser Rechner ist irgendwie nachweislich nicht mit Kabeln versehen gewesen. Also er war überhaupt nicht,
und äh man wirft ihm quasi die Konfiguration dieses Rechners vor, ohne jemals diese Konfiguration dieses Rechners jemals auch nur auf den Tisch gelegt zu haben.
Wenn man sie hätte, wie er meint, eben auch äh sehr wohl äh belegt hätte, dass dieser Rechner eben mit dieser ganzen Operation nichts äh zu tun hat. Und,
wesentlichen ist einfach die Verurteilung äh äh von von Bittersunde basiert eben auf Vorwürfen, die weder belegt sind noch in irgendeiner Form auch tatsächlich strafbar,
trotzdem kam es eben zu dieser Verurteilung. Einschließlich einer äh Ablehnung der der Wiederaufnahme,
des Falls auf Verfassungsgericht eben. Und das ja ist schon ein bisschen haarsträubend. Es gibt.
Petition auf Avas dot org ähm wo quasi man eben dran teilnehmen kann, um der Sache an sich mehr Aufmerksamkeit zu geben. Er sagt.
Es nicht seine Erwartung ist, dass jetzt diese Petition dazu führt, in irgendeiner Form hier nochmal so äh auf den letzten Metern einen Turnoran zu schaffen. Also es wird vermutlich nicht verhindern können, dass er eben dann tatsächlich auch in den Knast geht. Nur.
Ist es eben die goldene Gelegenheit, sagen wir mal, überhaupt auf diesen ganzen Zusammenhang, wie das jetzt gelaufen ist über die Jahre, hinzuweisen. Die Haarsträumse, äh das Haarströmste Detail ist ja dabei, er schildert dann eben,
wie er äh verhört worden ist von einem Polizisten, der irgendwie also,
Anwalt meinte auch, so was habe er in seinem Leben noch nie erlebt, ja, der so auf ihn eingeschrien hat und auf ihn äh
ein Druck ausgeübt hat wo die sich schon echt gefragt haben was ist mit dem Typen und später Monaten danach hatten dann in Recherche
Ergebnisse ergeben, dass dieser Typ,
mittlerweile von der Content-Industrie irgendwie von eingekauft worden ist und schon zwei Tage vorher die Zusage für seinen neuen Job hatte. Also er ist sozusagen direkt,
der polizeilichen Verfolgung äh in den Dienst äh
genau der Unternehmen getreten, die an der Stelle eben im Wesentlichen dahinter stehen, diesen diesen Fall nach vorne zu treiben, also die da sozusagen verklagen,
und so weiter. Also es ist wirklich ein haarsträubender Bericht,
Äh der einen wirklich nur noch fassungslos macht und äh ich kann echt alle nur auffordern, da,
äh sich einen Account zu klicken, wenn er nicht sowieso schon einen habt und da mal,
teilzunehmen, ne? Also so viel zu äh äh Schweden und seine äh Gesetzgebung, das ist Hardcore, ne.
Ja, ich würde da gerne eigentlich noch was noch was anderes zu anmerken und zwar diese Petition hat grade,
wirklich ärgerlich wenig Unterstützer überhaupt bis jetzt. Das sind irgendwie um die viertausend, ja? Ähm.
Ich habe in den letzten Wochen ähm hat ähm das jetzt ein.
Ein Vergleich, den ich eigentlich ungern mache, aber den muss man einfach mal an der Stelle ziehen. Äh Kim dot com, dieser mega Upload äh Gründer, der ja, sage ich mal, in dem Bereich Fileshaing im Prinzip ähm.
Also der hat der hat ja, sagen wir mal, man könnte einmal begegnen, indem man eine nicht-kommerzielle äh Idee aufbaut, wo wirklich
wird und irgendwie eine Infrastruktur hat. Man kann es aber natürlich auch wirklich
kommerziell aufsetzen, indem man äh eben so etwas macht wie mega, was das äh
besonders erleichtert, wo der Zugang zu größeren Datenmengen dann auch Geld kostet und man kann sich damit irgendwie ein Schloss in Neuseeland hinstellen und irgendwie sich
vollfressen und irgendwie eine auf dicke Hose machen, ja? Es sind also,
könnte sagen, dass Kim dot com so die die das die Anti-These zu Peterson ist, ja? Ähm,
Dieser kim dot com hat jetzt vor einiger Zeit äh wohl mit so einer absoluten Schamoffensive begonnen. Äh twittert jetzt irgendwie äh die ganze Zeit irgendwie Fotos ähm.
Kim Schmitz heißt der.
Den Gefallen ihn bei seinen Kindernamen da zu nennen irgendwie.
Kim Schmitz
twittert jetzt die ganze Zeit Fotos wo er mit seinen Kindern ist und macht da jetzt ein total auf auf den den Jesus der der Netzfreiheit der da irgendwie fertig gemacht werden soll ne? Ist also Multimillionär
der mit ähm.
Also auf jeden Fall mit Fightsharing, sei es nun äh rechtlich in Ordnung oder nicht. Äh auf jeden Fall durch unterhalten von Fallsherung, Infrastrukturen, sich äh sehr, sehr bereichert hat und auch verurteilt ist schon vorher wegen Insiderhandels und sonstwas und der sich
glaube ich, in Deutschland in Hackerkreisen schon seit zwanzig Jahren nicht mehr sehen zu lassen braucht, weil.
Der irgendwie andere Leute auch über den Tisch äh äh gezogen hat ohne Ende, mit Kreditkarten.
Dieser Typ.
Also der geht gar nicht.
Dieser Typ hat jetzt äh relativ bald einhunderttausend Follower bei Twitter,
stößt ein Mehmen nach dem anderen an, wo alle irgendwie ihm äh sagen, wie wie toll er ist und wir sind alle kim dot com
ja? Also wo du wirklich denkst, ja sowas liest man, also so wir sind alle, das hört man vielleicht bei bei äh äh urteilen gegen äh äh,
Todesurteilen gegen politische Gefangene oder sowas. Ja, da da gibt's dann mal so solche Sprüche wie, wir sind alle äh diese jene Person. Der hat jetzt hunderttausend Follower bei Twitter, freut sich irgendwie, dass er irgendwie bei Cloud äh score irgendwie einen höheren Punktezahl als äh Julian Assange hat
und ähm ist da jetzt offensichtlich stilisiert sich da jetzt echt zu zu diesem Netz Jesus, ja?
Und äh gleichzeitig siehst du Peter Sunde,
der wirklich einfach, der mal wirklich so ein Netz Jesus ist in meinen Augen, ja? Ähm der hat äh gerade mal viertausend Leute für so eine,
Für so eine blöde Petition da bis jetzt hat, wo es darum geht, dass das eher ernsthaft in Knast geht, ja und er ist eben nicht irgendwie Multimillionär geworden mit irgendeinem Konzern, mit dem er irgendwie,
sackweise die Leute abgezogen hat, ne, sondern der hat einfach nur äh ja, hat ein Pirate Bad Tracker unterhalten, so mehr nicht und weniger auch nicht.
Und Flatter gegründet.
Gegründet so. Er ist ein guter Mann und ich ich bin jetzt jedem sauer, der nicht diese Petition zeichnet.
Ja, also wenn ihr schon mal bei. Also wenn euch in eurem Leben schon mal ein paar Bits besorgt hat, die ihr dringend gebraucht habt.
Wirklich?
Müsstest du da gehen, oder? Ja, ja, doch, doch, auf jeden Fall, einige folgen.
Ja gut, ich denke nicht, dass primär darüber das bezogen wird, aber ihr wisst schon, ähm wenn euch also in irgendeiner Form das schon mal äh äh was gebracht hat, dann ist es sicherlich kein Fehler, dort äh mitzumachen.
Da bin ich echt halt mich ja jetzt mal zurück, aber ich kriege die Krise, wenn ich irgendwie, wenn ich so diese Zeitgleich, ja, wenn man sieht irgendwie Petersunde, schreibt da diesen Artikel über sein Verfahren und.
Mag da gar nicht drüber nachdenken, das irgendwie zu vergleichen. Ich meine, das ist sicherlich mal ganz angemessen, das zu tun. Hier geht's einfach wirklich äh mal um was äh relevant ist. Ich meine, ich bin mir am Ende auch sicher, dass man das schafft, irgendwie in äh sagen wir mal Auszeitenproblemen.
Zu befreien langfristig, aber.
Allein schon diese Knastgeschichte oder allein schon dieser, dieser wirklich Fischi Sieg äh ja auf absolut nicht rechtsstaatlichen Grundlagen geht gar nicht. Gut.
Thema.
Das ist eigentlich nur kurz daran und sich hat das Thema gerade fast schon rausgenommen. Es gab äh zweitausendzehn hatte die äh FCC, äh was heißt jetzt nochmal FCC Federal Communications Commission oder sowas? Ähm,
Genau, äh Federal Communications Commission hatte ähm zweitausendzehn in den USA auch so Netzneutralität festgeschrieben,
Was sie da aber gemacht haben war,
also wirklich so 'ne zahnlose Netzneutralität mit allen möglichen Ausnahmen, das heißt sie hatten nicht wirklich Netzneutralität da, ernsthaft ähm.
Implementiert, sondern es gab also eine Idee von so Netz muss neutral sein, solange legal und so und so und nicht für Netzinfrastrukturen notwendig und so weiter. Das heißt, sie haben da eigentlich gar nichts geregelt. Ähm
oder zumindest nichts an keine Regelung,
aufgestellt, die nicht irgendwo ein riesiggroßes Schlupfloch hätte. Ich hab das in einem Artikel damals relativ ausführlich behandelt, den hab ich auch nochmal verlinkt.
Und ich fand aber sehr schön, wie jetzt ähm einige US-Provider,
sich offensichtlich gegen diese Regelung zur Wehr setzen und das gebe ich einfach nun mal ohne weitere ohne weitere ähm ohne weiteren Kommentar jetzt einfach mal mit auf den Weg. Zwar haben sie gesagt, ähm,
Breitbandnetze sind die heutigen Mikrofone, über die ihre Besitzer ihre im ersten Verfassungszusatz festgeschriebenen Rederechte ausüben,
Das heißt.
Wenn das ähm wenn die Regierung hingeht oder wenn eine Behörde hingeht und Netzneutralität festschreibt, dann,
greift sie damit das Recht auf freie Meinungsäußerung der Provider.
Sky. Ja, es ist so äh voll dieser Style irgendwie und so. Mhm.
Geil, oder? Also brauchen wir, glaube ich, gar nicht weiter zu diskutieren.
Ähm also passt bitte auf, dass ihr auch die Redefreiheit eurer Provider äh beachtet, wenn ihr euch dann nächste Mal irgendwelche Seiten sperren und so, ne? Das ist einfach hier wichtig, ne? Grundrecht,
So, nur dass das auch mal klar geerdet ist.
Ach ja gut, dann war's das jetzt mal hier von äh.
Von von einer Meterebene aus diese Woche für Lokbuch äh äh der Netzpolitik. Nächste Woche haben wir wieder einen Termin, oder?
Nächste Woche haben wir wieder einen Termin.
Dann steht vermutlich danach auch mal wieder eine äh kleine äh Sende äh Pause, eine Urlaubsbedingte an, aber wir machen natürlich hier weiter.
So ist die Zeit erlaubt,
so euer Feedback uns da in der Richtung auch weiter äh motiviert über all das, was ihr bisher schon geschrieben habt, da bedanken wir uns,
aber werdet nicht müde, uns da auch äh Hinweise zu geben, auf neue Tipps oder wenn mal wieder was falsch war. Das kommt natürlich selten vor bei uns, aber man weiß ja nie.
Ja
Seufz. Gut. Ihr seid jetzt entlassen. Bis bald.
Oh Mann.